[Music]
welcome. Thank you for joining my
session this morning. I was thinking
that I was in some kind of niche space
where people would not be interested,
but I'm curious to hear, you know, what
brought you
to to this session. Anyway, I'm I'm
Jesus Barasa. I'm the I'm the field CTO
for AI with NEOJ and uh and yeah, for
the next like uh 14ish minutes, I'm
going to be diving a bit deeper into
this uh really powerful combination
which is knowledge graphs and uh and
large language models to build AI
applications and and in particular I'm
going to be focusing on this interesting
knowledge artifacts that are ontologies
and and how we can use them uh to get
some some practical wins in in our
favorite uh architecture which I'm sure
have heard about over the last couple of
days which is graph rag. I mean it is
part of this of this track. Um but um
anyway, even if you attended the the
workshops or or you didn't, I'm going to
spend a minute just refreshing what uh
what graph rag is. But basically, graph
rag is is your rag where you have
replaced your vector database with a
knowledge graph that's built on a on a
database on a graph database and uh and
the flow is is the same, right? So your
your AI application will get a prompt
from the user and instead of passing it
on to the LLM directly, what it will do
is we'll go out to a retrieval to a
control curated trusted uh sort of
knowledge base to retrieve potentially
relevant information that will be passed
to the LLM in the context window so that
the response or the task is accomplished
based on on more grounded uh information
rather than purely generated. So now the
the interesting thing of course is that
uh by using a knowledge graph what you
get is a much richer collection of
retrieval strategies and we're going to
see that uh you have not only the vector
semantic search over a vector index you
can also uh contextualize results
because a graph captures the connections
between data points so you're going to
be able we're going to go deeper in in
into how that happens is it also
possible to to generate structured
queries so there's a rich collection of
retrieval strategies like I was saying
that augments what you traditionally
have with you restrict yourself to only
vector search and and the result is that
you get uh better quality results uh
more completeness better completeness
more relevance better precision more
faithfulness a lot of metrics that I'm
sure have been mentioned over the last
couple of days and I won't spend too
much time but um but what does the graph
look like again uh especially for those
of you who have not familiar with this
but the we implements the property graph
model which has two main primitives is
nodes and relationships. Pretty simple.
So for us, nodes represent entities.
That's things, persons, objects,
locations, events, documents, anything.
And and they're connected to each other
with relationships that are directed.
And then these you can think of them as
objects that will have a collection of
key value pairs that characterize them
like description, uh like name, date of
birth, whatever. And uh this is what we
call the domain graph. Now the thing is
when we build a graph out of
unstructured data, we often enrich this
representation with what we call the uh
the lexical graph or some kind of form
of description of the of the source uh
documents uh from where we have
extracted the graph and and you can see
here that we will have a note
representing a document which maybe has
a sequence of chunks depending on how we
partition the document. It can be in the
simplest case a sequential list of
chunks. But if it's think of a legal
document like a a contract with
sections, subsections like definitions,
clauses, you might have a richer kind of
tree description of what that document
looks like. Uh and and that would be
represented also as a graph. Now of
course these chunks then will be
connected to the domain uh graph by uh
entity extraction. So we'll find that
this person is mentioned in this chunk
and we'll keep track of where that's me
that's mentioned because we're going to
use that when we do the the retrieval
right and um and one interesting thing
to keep in mind here is that uh these
properties that we store in a node can
also well can be numeric can be string
can be all sorts of data types but it
can also be vectors. So these chunks
will typically contain the text the raw
text that you have uh uh in which you
have you have split your document but
you can also have the vectorzed
representation and then you can index
it. So you it's it's pretty compelling
the fact that you can have in the same
platform a vector storage with uh
enriched with uh with um with the
connected representation that the graph
brings. Now of course in order to get to
to graph rag you have to build a graph.
There's no graph rack without a graph.
And depending how uh you where you're
getting your data from whether it's
structure or unstructured you probably
will follow different uh type of of
pipelines right so if you look at the
more structured approach you will have
some uh maybe tabular representation in
some database or even files you will
have some description of the target
schema the graph that you want to build
and you would map those basically saying
in the simplest case these records will
populate these type of nodes these are
the records will define the
relationships and you will write that to
the graph what you have here in the URL
is is the the the UI the the interface
that our product offers and basically it
does what I was describing here in a
visual way. So you define your graph
model, you map to your data sources, you
map the you connect the dots and and you
get a graph generated behind of course
is an API base and you can do the same
thing programmatically. But important to
understand that you have to pass the
target schema. We're going to get to
that in a minute. If you're loading uh
you're building a graph out of
structured data and this is the pipeline
that our graph rack package follows. But
if you look at our integration with lang
chain with LA index, it will look pretty
much the same. What you're doing is
you're processing the document. you will
split it in some way based on what we
described before. you will take these
chunks and you will embed them and you
will run this kind of entity extraction
process that I was mentioning before to
which you will have to inject your your
schema right so you'll have to tell what
kind of entities do I care about what's
the my domain of this course am I
looking at uh medical documents where
I'm going to find information about
patients and and symptoms am I looking
at you know financial information like
account holders accounts you know money
transfers etc so that's the kind of
information that you find in the schema
and then ultimately you will write it to
the graph But the common bit there is
the fact that we have to inject that
schema and that's where things diverge
because depending on the path that you
follow maybe you know this approach will
have a a JSON based representation of
your entities and the relationships.
Maybe here you're using something like a
pyantic description of the kind of
entities that you want to get or even a
natural language one if you're prompting
you know your your your LLM to to do the
extraction. Now this divergence is
something that's uh you know not ideal
to manage and what you want to do is
have some kind of agnostic and and and
general approach to to representing
schemas and that's exactly what
ontologies bring and an ontology is just
a shared you know description of of a
domain. You can think of it as a as a
formal schema that's that's
implementation agnostic. And what's
interesting and looking at ontologies uh
there's a bunch of of standards for
defining ontologies and there's a some
of them defining by the W3C. They can be
serialized in a number of ways. I've
picked the XML one. Why not? Who's using
XML in 2025? But anyway, there's JSON
based as well. There's many others,
right? The important thing is what an
ontology describes is exactly what we're
after which is a domain, right? So you
will find a definition of a class which
actually matches very well what a what a
graph model looks like. So this is a
fragment of the fiber ontology which is
the financial uh industry uh um
ontology. That's a public one and and
you see the definition of a of um what's
it there like a privately held company.
I don't know if you can read it there
but anyway there's another class there
that's a stock corporation. We are
specifying that one is a subcategory of
the other. So there's a subclass of this
you know relationship between the two of
them. Then there's even connections
between classes of other nature. For
example, we say that a stock corporation
is governed by a board agreement, right?
So these all these sort of elements are
described in the ontology and that's a
perfect you know like I was saying uh
implementation agnostic approach to uh
to drive the knowledge graph creation
and that will work for both uh pipelines
the structured and the unstructured and
my but basically my my take on this is
is um fundamentally be be model driven
right because the the not only because
it's a data engineering but good
practice but also because uh it will
build a better graph in the first place
and uh and it will pay dividends in in
in the long run. And we're going to see
that in the retrieval phase because if
you have a good description of your
graph, your text to structured query is
going to generate better and more
accurate queries, but also when we use
the the vector plus contextualization,
that's going to pay off as well. You
have there an example of of use of
anontology to to populate a graph with
structured and unstructured data. I
don't have time to go over that today,
but you can you can have a look there.
Now on the retrieval side of things, let
me spend a minute explaining how this
magic happens because I said that you
have a better retrieval strategies,
richer ones and um and what's happening
there. You see uh that the graph
captures and I'm going to use a visual.
Bear with me. I hope that's that's
useful. So you have a graph, right? And
the graph some of those nodes will
contain pieces of text, the chunks that
we have embedded. So when we embed them
and put them in a vector index, we're
effectively creating a new search space.
Like think of these as a new you know
way of entering the the graph right so a
a search in that space would be a you
embed your query that defines a point in
your multi-dimensional space and you
will find vectors in the vicinity so
that's what you do when you do a vector
search right so the interesting thing is
that in the graph when you find the the
the vectors that are in proximity
because these vectors are properties of
a node we can dreference them and get
back to the graph and from there we can
contextualize we can navigate and enrich
and filter out aggregate. So that's
where we do the contextualization and we
can bring uh additional richness to the
to the to the context that we pass to
the to the LLM. Now what does that look
like in in code? So oh I don't know if
it's going to be readable but um let's
read for the b from the bottom map. So
this is again a fragment from our graph
package python package but if you look
at the the integration with lang chain
is going to be very very similar. So we
do a we do a search we specify we pass a
a query. This is a movie database where
we're looking for uh we have embedded
and put in a vector index the plots of
the movies, right? So we're looking for
something you can imagine the movie that
I'm looking for, right? We're looking
for a computer hacker that discovers
that the world he knows is simul is
simulated reality controlled by
machines. So that's my search uh uh term
and I'm passing that to my retriever and
specifying I want the top three results.
That's my that's for me to decide. And
basically what I'm doing is I've created
this handler that that's a handler over
the vector index and all I'm doing is
telling it to do this search but I'm
passing a retrieval query. So basically
what you see up here is this retrieval
query which is basically the logic the
exploration logic that I'm running of on
every single result that I get from my
vector index. Right? So that's um that's
powerful. That's great. Now there is a
kind of a problem there. And my problem
is that um in order to create this
retriever, I need to know my model. I
need to be familiar with the fact that
my graph contains actors that acted in
movies that these movies have have plots
and things like that. And and that
introduces I mean that that's that's
great, but to some extent is is a little
bit rigid because I have to hardcode
part of the logic in my retriever. So
how could I work around that? Well, the
great thing is that if we take the
ontology that we saw before and we
persist it in the graph, now we have the
graph of our data, our movie database,
and we have an ontology that describes
that schema. What I can do is create a
dynamic query. And I understand that you
guys are not cipher experts, but you
know,
if you bear with me on that, I mean,
what we're doing is I'm I'm querying my
ontology where there's a definition of a
relationship. So I know that actors act
in movies and there's a definition of
this relationship. That's what my domain
model describes. Now I'm going to query
that and I'm looking for relationships
that I have annotated as contextualizing
relationships. So I'm defining a
subcategory in this case, subropy of. So
what I can do is drive the behavior of
my retriever by consulting the ontology.
So I look at the ontology, I find the
relationships that have been specified
as contextualizing relationships and
those are the ones that I navigate. So
this R is the one that I'm using to then
find nodes that are connected to other
things. So in other words, my ontology
is driving the behavior of this query
and it's determining the fact that when
I find the movie, the matrix, I'm going
to I'm going to be navigating just the
actor in relationships and not the
producer, the directed. Right? I
understand that, you know, it might be
going a bit too deep into into the the
cipher aspect without having you you
know you train a little bit on it, but I
hope I hope it makes sense. I mean the
idea is that's another way in which
ontologies can drive can give us a kind
of a a level of indirection that makes
it possible for us to kind of build
dynamic retrievers that are driven by
data. So I can change my ontology and by
changing my ontology which is a data
artifact in my graph I'm changing the
behavior of my retriever uh on the fly
and the and dynamically. So that that's
what I wanted to share with you. So the
two takeaways I mean the first one is
ontologies for knowledge graph creation
as an uh uh implementation agnostic uh
um data model and the second one storing
ontology can help us drive uh dynamic
behavior in our retrievers. That's what
I had for you today and just in time. So
thank you very much and happy to take
the questions or the conversation back
to our booth. Cheers.
[Music]